[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa es uno de los más
grandes escándalos de espionaje a nivel
global una investigación reveló que
periodistas activistas y jefes de estado
estaban siendo vigilados a través de
pegasus un programa que fue creado para
combatir el crimen y que durante años se
vende a gobiernos de todo el mundo se
cree que más de 50 mil teléfonos eran
potenciales objetivos de vigilancia pero
que es pegasus que hacen su teléfono
quien lo creó y que dice esta empresa
sobre las acusaciones pero sobre todo
quiénes fueron las presuntas víctimas de
espionaje empezamos
las denuncias sobre ciudadanos siendo
espiados por gobiernos lamentablemente
no son una novedad pero el mundo se
sorprendió al saber que un software que
solo debería usarse para combatir el
terrorismo y la delincuencia se estaba
utilizando presuntamente para vigilar a
periodistas activistas de derechos
humanos y altos políticos a nivel
mundial se trata del programa pegasus
fabricado por la empresa de tecnología
israelí
ns o group el hallazgo fue producto de
una investigación en la que trabajaron
17 organizaciones de medios y las ong
forbidden stories y amnistía
internacional y se produjo tras la
filtración de una lista de más de 50.000
números telefónicos que se creen eran
potenciales objetivos de espionaje de
esta lista pudieron identificar a más de
1000 personas en 50 países y luego de
examinar 67 teléfonos encontraron que en
37 de ellos había rastros del software
pero no está claro cuántos dispositivos
fueron alcanzados
al momento de grabar este programa los
reportes indicaban que entre los
potenciales objetivos había más de 180
periodistas de medios como new york
times' al yazira y france24 y también
unos 600 políticos incluyendo al menos
14 líderes mundiales de la lista de los
50.000 números telefónicos la mayor
cantidad está en méxico con más de
15.000 según el portal británico the
guardian al menos 50 personas cercanas
al presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador fueron blancos potenciales de la
administración de su predecesor enrique
peña nieto en francia el periódico the
moon alertó que el número del presidente
manuel mayor figuraba en la lista lo que
llevó al mandatario a cambiar su línea y
su dispositivo móvil de acuerdo con el
washington post también están incluidos
los teléfonos de los presidentes de
sudáfrica e irak pero no se pudo
determinar si estos celulares pudieron
ser infiltrados también se encontró que
los dispositivos de personas cercanas al
periodista saudí llama al hashtag y
fueron atacados con pegasus antes y
después de su muerte en 2018
katia justa de amnistía internacional en
francia habla de los peligros del uso de
programas como
pegasus lo que muestran estas
revelaciones es que en manos de
gobiernos represivos por ejemplo el
software espía se puede utilizar
eficazmente para silenciar a defensores
de derechos humanos periodistas para
aplastar a la oposición por lo que las
consecuencias en términos de derechos
humanos son muy graves y como podemos
ver muy a menudo los ataques digitales
también tienen repercusiones
potencialmente muy graves en el mundo
físico con detenciones desapariciones e
incluso asesinatos pero que es
exactamente pegasus es un programa
malicioso también llamado malware que se
instala en un dispositivo sin previo
aviso y sin el consentimiento de su
dueño expertos lo definen como el
software espía más poderoso que jamás se
haya desarrollado según los autores de
la investigación pegasus puede llegar
hasta un teléfono por medio de
mensajería de texto oa través de
vulnerabilidades desconocidas en el
dispositivo advierten que aunque en
algunos casos es necesario que la
víctima haga clic en un enlace para
descargar el malware sus fabricantes se
las han ingeniado para que el
dispositivo se infecte con tan solo
recibir un mensaje una modalidad
conocida como cero clic y que no produce
ninguna notificación
en el teléfono pegasus puede acceder al
micrófono la cámara así como las
llamadas chats fotos contactos y
ubicación así lo explica alojaron
richard director y fundador de forbidden
stories
es un ataque invisible contra la
democracia ese software realmente se usa
para saber todo sobre ti no sólo
directamente de ti sino también de las
personas con las que estás hablando de
tus hijos de tu esposa de tu esposo de
tu conductor de tu médico vemos que no
hay control en absoluto y que pueden
apuntar a quien quiera
joel de que el target sub the board
pegasus es desarrollada por la empresa
tecnológica israelí en ese o group
dedicada a la creación de programas de
vigilancia según la compañía este tipo
de productos se venden exclusivamente a
las agencias gubernamentales de
inteligencia para garantizar la
seguridad nacional eso último reporte
dicen que tienen 60 clientes ubicados en
40 países aunque se negaron a revelar
sus identidades citando acuerdos de
confidencialidad forbidden stories y los
medios asociados encontraron que muchos
de los números telefónicos que figuraban
como objetivos
agrupados en 10 países méxico hungría
india ruanda marruecos azerbaiyán bar en
kazajistán
arabia saudita y emiratos árabes en una
serie de respuestas a la investigación
en ese o grupo aclaró que aunque vende
la licencia a sus clientes no opera el
programa pegasus ni tiene conocimiento
de cómo has usado por ellos los números
de la lista no están relacionados con el
grupo de ns o no operamos el sistema ni
tenemos acceso a los datos de nuestros
clientes sin embargo están obligados a
proporcionarnos dicha información
durante las investigaciones
ns o investigar a fondo cualquier prueba
creíble del uso indebido de sus
tecnologías como siempre lo hicimos y
cerrará el sistema cuando sea necesario
las denuncias sobre espionaje han
suscitado al rechazo de los medios de
comunicación así titulan algunos de los
más importantes el periódico francés le
parisien dedicó una editorial al tema
titulado democracia bajo ataque el
servicio de radiodifusión alemana
deutsche welle dice pegasus el arma
cibernética favorita de los dictadores
la cadena británica bbc se pregunta nos
estamos convirtiendo todos en espías sin
saberlo y crítica como gracia
a su venta los sistemas de vigilancia y
espionaje están en manos de países e
incluso individuos un artículo de
opinión del diario mexicano 'el
universal' dice que el problema no es
pegaso sino la existencia de un aparato
de inteligencia sin controles adecuados
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir esta u otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto para
veinticuatro punto com